when I go to a movie what's gonna happen
I have that that sense of wonderment
stays with me
buzz it hi I'm Larry King and I love
movies the best place to see a movie is
in a big movie theater with the popcorn
and the whole works
nothing beats a big screen I like the
trailers I like the whole atmosphere and
my wife buys popcorn during the trailers
how could you not watch trailers I love
the movies of today the movies of
yesterday I love black and white movies
my favorite movie of all time is
Godfather and Godfather 2 is right there
they had everything you'd want in a film
that is they had drama had violence
there was a family it was soap opera SH
but on a grand scale kept young the
pinzón eBoost you could watch it anytime
you'd watch it 10 times it was still
great - vows incredible Brando was in
top form
Pacino at the top of his game you're my
older brother and I love you but don't
ever take sides with anyone against the
family again I mean I know it's ALPA
Chino but when he's up on the screen
whatever character he is he's that
character and you suspend your disbelief
to north and you know I got over the
Wow's when I started interviewing them
early but it's always a kick because I
have great respect for the acting art
every great actor is very intelligent so
when I get a chance to sit with these
people
I get that blessing of getting an
education for free a great appreciation
for the crafts enjoyment comes in many
degrees enjoyment can come from a deep
drama enjoyment can come from a comedy
if I don't like the script I might like
the performance yeah I love movies take
tote never done that
you